et dès qu'on refuse de rentrer dans leur
jeu et vous traitez immédiatement après
de [ __ ] et ils ont la claque au bout
des doigts et il insulte au bord de la
bouche
faut-il en rire ou faut-il en pleurer de
4 ans à 72 ans on peut subir des
agressions sexuelles en effet votre
courrier en témoigne que ce soit des
attouchements très localisés pendant la
petite enfance ou des obscénités jetés
au visage même quand on est grand-mère
il n'y a pas de limite il n'y a pas de
règle fixées pour être victime de ce
genre de choses d'ailleurs où commence
l'agression sexuelle c'est ce que nous
tenterons de dire au cours de l'émission
nous n'y parlerons pas du viol qui est
la plus grave enfin des agressions
sexuelles mais auxquelles nous avons
déjà consacré une émission faut-il en
rire ou faut-il en pleurer dans
l'ensemble vous n'avez pas tellement
envie d'Henri ces hommages masculins
très spéciaux vous révoltent très
souvent et vous êtes plutôt contente
qu'on brise le silence sur ce sujet mais
faut-il en rire quand même c'est ce que
nous verrons au cours de l'émission
qui s'est passé au moment de la
préparation de cette émission en
conférence de rédaction lorsque Gaëlle
on l'a eu a proposé cette émission je
dois dire que parmi les journalistes qui
étaient là certains sont demandés et le
plus souvent d'ailleurs des journalistes
masculins s'il y avait là une réalité
enfin c'est un sujet qui valait qu'on en
parle et nous sommes dit le meilleur
moyen de savoir c'est de demander à nos
téléspectatrices s'il y a la matière à
faire une émission votre courrier a
apporté la réponse les lettres qui nous
sont arrivés sont très nombreuses et
témoignent qu'il y a vraisemblablement
un problème dont tout le monde s'en
doute n'a pas conscience alors on va
commencer par des témoignages ça sera
peut-être le plus éclairant les
téléspectatrices qui sont avec nous
aujourd'hui sont 5
madame Gasquet puisque vous voici vous
vous apportez votre témoignage de choses
quand même surprenantes voir
désagréables dans vous avez été l'objet
il y a certains tonnes déjà
est-ce qu'il est possible comme ça
des roues comme un pourquoi suite de
quoi dans quelles circonstances
bon ben voilà dans le métro et c'était
une heure d'affluence et on était comme
on dit chez nous ce qui fait comme les
enfants
et impossible de se garer là il y avait
une affaire
[Musique]
il va donc moi cette poche
et encore maintenant
je n'aurais pas
j'ai toujours
adoré le cinéma
avant de me
à l'ouvrage j'avais la précaution de
dire au préalable
qu'elle me trouve un petit coin
tranquille c'est quoi elle comprend très
bien ce que je voulais dire près de près
d'autres dames exactement l'endroit où
je ne sois pas un portugais par parce
que alors dans les cinémas c'est
terrible c'est terrible ce qui se passe
et cette fois là elle m'a dit vous savez
c'est bon dire je sais pas trop je vais
vous caser il me place
sur un strapontin à côté de chez moi il
y a une dame
de pleurer
l'héroïne elle n'avait pas de mourir et
j'ai ressenti une gêne sous le bras
qu'est-ce que c'est pourtant
vous pouvez pas me toucher
je me suis lavé d'un bon j'ai poussé un
cri
je suis quand même c'est pas possible
c'est
infernal ça on peut pas rester
tranquille minute
parce que après tout bon elles sont
souvent les mêmes quel est c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il en porte chez vous c'est
la peur c'est la négation c'est le
je suis pas pour eux je suis pas une
femme
jamais peur je peux quand vraiment je
sens que à ce moment-là j'essaie de de
me garer du danger si bon boulot sur la
tête je reste pas là et subir je non
j'ai pas peur ce que c'est j'ai surtout
ça je me suis bien analysé vous voyez
j'ai un sentiment de colère de colère de
rage de rage de rage
mais moi je froide vous savez et surtout
d'un puissance
envers ses agressions comment je est-ce
que moi je vais par exemple
un monsieur un monsieur ou un jeune
homme nous est plus
c'est normal est-ce que nous allons
certaine façon de leur faire comprendre
qu'il nous serait agréable
[Applaudissements]
qui est chef de la sûreté à Marseille
est-ce que quelqu'un comme ça qui tend
des attouchements dans un cinéma si les
contrarié si on se défend peut devenir
dangereux est-ce que vous avez des
exemples
lorsque l'homme se conduit ainsi et que
la femme réagit la façon dont gasquier
réagit une façon très saine à ce
moment-là la plupart du temps l'homme ne
demande pas Suarez il s'en va et ça
c'est à peu près je n'ai pas d'exemple
moi d'hommes qui est si vous voulez en
quelque sorte commis ensuite des actes
de violence physique en quelque sorte
sur la personne qui est ainsi manifesté
son mécontentement mais malheureusement
ce que je regrette c'est que la plupart
du temps les victimes car nous parlons
de victimes ne signalent pas c'est fait
le signal peut-être de leur entourage
mais ne les signalent pas si vous voulez
au service de police ne signale pas la
police urbaine
nous regrettons nous ne pas être informé
il serait utile de savoir que dans tel
cinéma par exemple nous avons plus de
ces individus qu'ailleurs car en fin de
compte ce n'est pas dans tous les
cinémas également disons qu'il y a
certains cinémas qui sont plus
tranquilles que d'autres
est-ce que est-ce que ce genre de
d'attitude est
répréhensible au regard de la loi c'est
un acte de violence et automatiquement
cette l'individu qui sera coupable de
cet acte à ce moment-là nous l'entendons
et la cassation nous présentons aux
autorités judiciaires incontestablement
je vous invite à écouter avec nous aussi
elle peut témoigner de c'est un degré
peut-être supplémentaire encore dans
l'escalade si je puis dire de
différentes circonstances qu'elle a vécu
fort peu agréable
le plus tard se passe dans le métro
donc dans le métro c'est très souvent je
prends un exemple parmi dans d'autres
parce que sur quoi j'en auraient
beaucoup à raconter
c'était un soir j'attendais mon mari à
Gare de l'Est et j'étais assise sur sur
le bon en attendant ma correspondance et
j'ai deux jeunes petits garçons je peux
dire des petits garçons parce qu'ils
avaient peut-être 9 ans 10 ans en plus
et ce sont ainsi à côté de moi et d'un
seul coup ils m'ont ouvert un livre
devant moi alors je suis porté forcément
les yeux dessus et c'était un livre
pornographique avec des photos en
couleur vraiment
alors la première réaction s'arrêtait de
me rebeller disons vis-à-vis de cet
enfant mais j'ai dit c'est quand même
qu'un enfant alors j'ai refermé le livre
et puis je lui ai redonné j'ai dit mais
tu as pas autre chose à lire tu préfères
pas un livre de cow-boy de policiers
enfin j'ai tourné ça autrement parce que
je pouvais pas me dégager je savais pas
comment lui dire à ce garçon alors il me
dit oh non
moi je lis ça d'ailleurs mon père il lit
que ça et celui qui me l'a passé il est
parti on rigole est-ce que vous pensez
pas que c'était un petit peu différent
parce que s'il avait 9 ou 10 ans cet
enfant
possible si je puis dire c'était plutôt
provocateur non je crois oui
quel est votre attitude vous parce que
bon je sais vous nous le disiez dans la
lettre que vous avez reçu que vous avez
fait l'objet de choses plus puissante et
moins agréable quel est votre attitude
dans ce genre de
circonstances est-ce que comme Madame
c'est l'alignation enfin qui l'emporte
ou la peur ou la puissance
que la première action c'est la peur
châtelain un jour enfin je résume d'une
phrase dans un lieu de banlieue assez
désert et un peu inquiétant ça se
passait mal est-ce que vous avez après
avoir un être sorti indem si je puis
dire est-ce que vous avez signalé
l'effet porter plainte non je l'ai dit à
ma mère tout de suite parce que j'étais
tellement terrorisée
beaucoup de femmes sont agressées comme
ça c'est quelque chose qui est presque
sinon normal du moins habituel oui
parce qu'il y a une part de honte
[Musique]
nous prennent pas au sérieux
une explication à ce silence à cette
difficulté de parler des agressions
qu'on a suivi
je pense que
en partie oui il y a toute une
culpabilité sans doute déjà à oser aller
en parler comme s'ils en étaient
eux-mêmes ils les avaient suscités enfin
il y a sans doute tout un aspect
sociologique en fin des choses se sentir
coupable alors qu'on est plutôt victime
alors tout le problème c'est ce qu'on
est victime et ce qu'on est un objet
c'est autour de choses comme ça qu'on
peut en parler
là vous disiez vous parliez de ces
petits garçons et c'est intéressant
parce que vous avez dit leur père fait
pareil la réponse là avec elle
mais je pense que les agressions
sexuelles proposent le problème de la
sexualité en général la sexualité des
adultes et de la sexualité des enfants
et ma position étant que en somme
la sexualité des adultes sous des
modalités autres mais étant germe dans
la sexualité des enfants l'enfant n'est
pas ce petit ange qu'on a parfois eu
tendance à montrer donc par exemple
l'exemple à donner de ces petits garçons
de de 9-10 ans de vous paraît pas
surprenant
c'est des choses qui arrivent enfin nous
avons d'autres exemples dans le courrier
de d'agression enfin agression sexuelle
c'est peut-être un grand mot mais de
gestes effectivement déplacés le nom de
la part de petit garçon de 12 ans je
crois que vous le sujet agression
sexuelle qu'est-ce que c'est le mot
agression enfin est-ce que là c'est
vraiment une agression est-ce que c'est
une attitude de provocation de la part
de ces deux petits garçons enfin c'est
difficile de répondre comme ça est-ce
que c'est pour faire comme leur père
est-ce que fin donc je pense que
tant sur l'homosexuel que sur le mot
agression il y a toute une gamme
qualitative ou quantité enfin ça me
paraît difficile peut-être de parler
d'emblée peut-être d'agression ça dépend
comment réagit l'agression c'est par
rapport à celui qui l'a subi pour
illustrer davantage notre propos un
autre exemple c'est celui que nous
offrez madame lorientz c'est une
histoire qui commençait bien et puis qui
a failli finir c'est tout le temps nos
champignons j'en ai mon petit-fils pour
l'aérer il s'est endormi je l'ai couché
dans la voiture et comme nous venions
d'arriver j'essaie de partir ouverte que
j'ai pas trouillé tout autour de la
voiture environ sur quoi 25 mètres
quelques ou 50 m je ne sais pas où je
suis tomber sur une place de trompette
de la mort et à ce moment-là une voiture
qui est passée dans un sens et puis dans
l'autre et j'ai continué à ramasser mes
champignons et puis tout d'un coup en
tendant une brindille craquée j'ai pensé
que c'était mon petit-fils qui s'était
réveillé et qui venait j'ai levé le nez
j'ai vu un individu de 22 23 ans via
balancer Jeanne bonjour en survêtement
et qui était en train d'exhiber ce qu'il
pensait avoir de mieux je suppose
et alors je me suis relevé bien sûr je
lui ai dit oh bah non on figurait pas
qu'à mon âge vous allez me faire peur
avec des histoires comme celle-là allez
vous en
il m'a dit alors c'est pas un bon pied
ça
et je lui ai dit non foutez-moi le camp
d'ailleurs j'ai un enfant dans la
voiture
et puis je parle plus loin il a remonté
son pantalon
et il a couru sur la voiture alors là
j'ai une part épouvantable jusqu'à
présentable me dire mon Dieu qu'est-ce
qu'il va faire qu'est-ce qui va se
passer alors du coup derrière et puis il
a contourné la voiture est-ce qu'il a vu
qu'il y avait effectivement un enfant je
ne sais pas mais l'un derrière l'autre
on a fait tout le tour et il est parti
il a disparu dans les forêts alors à ce
moment-là je suis montée en voiture le
petit dormet je suis continuer à
ramasser mon petit mes champignons
j'ai eu une part épouvantable en me
disant si je n'avais pas démarrer
qu'est-ce qui va se passer alors je vais
fermer toutes les portières
qu'est-ce que je ferai je klaxonnerai
enfin ça c'est très bien passé je suis
partie j'ai regardé tous les côtés je
n'ai pas vu cette voiture arrêtée elle
devait être caché dans un fourré et j'ai
rencontré une voiture de police qui va
trouée dans la forêt de haie je leur ai
signalé la chose ils avaient l'air au
courant d'ailleurs parce qu'ils m'ont
demandé si c'était un jeune s'il avait
de grands cheveux
et puis c'est tout je suis rentrée chez
moi j'ai signalé ça à la maison en en
riant d'ailleurs et en disant tout le
monde est arrivé devant
dans ce genre de situation vous seriez
plutôt de celle qui est sérieux et qui
essaierait du moins de tenir tête
je me suis posé la question après et je
me suis dit bon bah si j'avais été
vraiment agressé d'ailleurs je me suis
demandé est-ce qu'il m'aurait agressé
effectivement ou ce que ce serait resté
au stade de l'exhibition d'autre part
est-ce qu'il voulait prendre l'enfant
c'est surtout ça que j'ai eu peur
qu'est-ce que j'aurais fait c'est pas
moi
là je me suis dit qu'en coup de pied
bien placé ce serait peut-être efficace
nous verrons plus loin dans le débat
d'ailleurs quelle réaction serait-il
souhaitable d'avoir je voudrais encore
demander aux deux téléspectatrices qui
n'ont pas été présentés de donner leur
témoignage d'un doyen à vous pas
d'agression violente mais très souvent
dans les collèges il est subir enfin la
provenance de ces messieurs alors au
début on croit que ce sont des cartables
ou par exemple si c'est une imaginaire
sans trop faire si et finalement bon au
début je suis paralysée par la peur et
jusqu'au jour je me suis dit ça peut pas
durer comme ça alors j'ai pris mon
courage à deux mains j'ai carrément
donné une paire de gifles et depuis vous
vous sentez mieux depuis je me sens plus
en sécurité et plusieurs moi-même enfin
j'étais en face c'est fière de moi et
moi ça me met en colère disons que vous
pensez il faut en parler des agressions
sexuelles c'est quelque chose
d'important qui arrive souvent
donc dans les transports en commun parce
que je crois que ça arrive peut-être des
centaines de fois par jour
vous raconter ça dans votre entourage à
votre mari à vos amis est-ce qu'on vous
dites
mademoiselle maire vous vous avez 17 ans
vous êtes encore au lycée
des agressions sexuelles donc vous avez
été victime ou plutôt un sentiment
général de oui ce serait plutôt un
sentiment général de ne pas pouvoir me
promener dans la rue de sortir pour
faire n'importe quoi à aller faire une
course ou aller au cinéma sans avoir à
subir des regards mais vraiment enfin je
sais pas des regards vraiment qui qui
déshabillent des tas de des paroles
il y a des regards quand même qui sont
enfin je sais pas regarder je ne sais
pas mais
vraiment des regards qui vous
déshabillent et c'est vraiment très
désagréable
et vous vous le vivez comme une
agression oui moi je le vis comme une
agression et vous vous défendre et
d'ailleurs oui j'essaie mais c'est pas
facile de quelle manière j'essaye de me
révolter c'est à dire de me dire que
quand même j'ai bien le droit de me
promener dans la rue et de
micro
j'ai bien droit de me promener dans la
rue sans avoir à subir tout ce qui peut
m'entourer puis ça ne s'arrête pas vous
savez au regard il y a aussi les paroles
les gestes enfin c'est quand même varié
de faire la même chose oui mais vous
savez j'ai une amie qui a fait ça qui a
abordé un un garçon
en faisant exactement le même manège
mais à l'inverse elle était bien embêtée
parce que le garçon a à marcher alors
vous savez c'est quand même
que ça soit qu'au femme que ça arrive ce
genre de situation
non je suis pas du tout étonné mais je
voudrais enfin je ne suis pas tellement
d'accord avec l'ironie de l'intervention
de Monsieur je pense qu'effectivement
l'agression sexuelle commence au regard
et que cette comparaison que vous faites
entre le regard qu'une femme
éventuellement peut porter sur un homme
pour lui manifester sa sympathie ou
éventuellement son désir n'a strictement
rien de comparable avec les regards dont
nous sommes criblés parce qu'on se
demandait s'il fallait parler de
victimes ou d'objets de l'agression
sexuelle moi je dirais même de cible
donc ça n'a strictement rien de
comparable avec les regards dont nous
sommes continuellement criblés dans nos
moines dans le moindre de nos
déplacements et je trouve assez
impressionnant que d'après ce qui vient
d'être dit là que ça soit dans la forêt
que ça soit dans dans le métro que ça
soit dans le cinéma que ça soit dans le
trolley que ça soit dans la rue que ça
soit même dans le petit périmètre qui
entoure notre maison les femmes ne
peuvent pas n'ont pas le droit
finalement elles sont dans un territoire
qui qui dans lequel elles sont en danger
la vie ne pourra un territoire dans
laquelle dans lequel elles sont en
danger et à partir de là je ne vois pas
tellement si on peut se poser la
question de pouvons-nous rire de ça
enfin en l'occurrence bon
cet état de fait doit mobiliser doit
déclencher comme la dame le disait la
rage l'indignation et et il faut en
parler il faut pouvoir se défaire de
cette impuissance de cette façon de se
sentir complètement démunis mal à l'aise
honteuse presque qu'on éprouve parfois
madame doyen est-ce que vous êtes déjà
allé porter plainte et comme des fois
failli tourner assez mal bon ben je me
suis défendue j'étais obligé de mort
donc la personne et le lendemain le
lendemain avec une camarade et si vous
allez au commissariat de enfin porter
plainte et on m'a accueilli avec le
sourire on me fait comprendre cette
élection plein puisque en fait je
n'avais rien eu donc il y avait aucune
raison de faisant le moment disant bon
bah
donc il n'y a pas eu de suite à votre
plâtre et vous habitez
que bon ben la police enfin aurait pu
faire ou me montrer qu'elle aurait pu
essayer de faire quelque chose
que je voudrais dire c'est à propos de
la question qui a été posée tout à
l'heure de pourquoi bien souvent les
femmes ne se pas réagir n'osent pas
porter plainte pourquoi même parfois
elle en parle elle n'en parle pas
vraiment autour d'elle et ben je crois
que c'est exactement comme pour le viol
et là encore il y a pas une une
différence si cassée en ce que entre ce
qui serait d'une part l'agression
sexuelle et d'autre par ceux qui
seraient le viol et de l'autre côté ceux
qui seraient le regard je pense que
d'emblée bien souvent la femme qui a été
accosté la femme qui a été a touchée la
femme qui a été offensée par un
spectacle comme ça au coin de d'un
couloir de métro elle elle peut-être
qu'au fond d'elle-même elle se demande
si elle serait pas un peu coupable de
quelque chose elle elle a été tellement
conditionnée à être celle qui allume
celle qui provoque celle qui est celle
qui est le péché celle qui est plein de
mauvaises intentions que au fond
d'Allemagne elle elle est brouillée dans
son esprit et elle ne sait même plus
vraiment exactement ce qu'il en est
exactement comme pour le viol ou
toujours au fond au fin fond de l'esprit
de la femme elle se demande finalement
où elle en est par rapport à ça tout est
fait pour accentuer cette impression que
vous aviez dit tout à l'heure que vous
ne vouliez pas en rire mais j'ai
peut-être quand même un exemple pour
illustrer ce que vous venez de dire vous
allez écouter nous allons écouter
ensemble si vous le voulez bien un
sketch de Guy bedo celui il s'agit
peut-être des provocations des femmes
écouter attentivement
[Applaudissements]
alors alors qu'est-ce qui reste
qu'est-ce qui reste ma femme
[Musique]
Josette de ne pas prendre la pilule pour
garder la ligne Totet est tellement
déformé par les grossesses quand on les
accouchements
il faut lutter contre l'assouplissement
sexuel humanile docteur je lutte docteur
je lui dis je l'avais pas eu celle-là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame cherravinou qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du traitement des femmes dans ce
sketch enfin cet homme est en train de
regarder un magazine de pornographie
probablement et on sent qu'il a envie de
passer aux actes
vous êtes choqués par ce sketch
par le mot qu'il emploie ça vous quelle
réaction ça vous avez
on dirait qu'il veut nous
gêner par les paroles
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
c'est exagéré ou ce genre de
plaisanterie de paillardes sont des
choses courantes
oui surtout à l'époque de la ministre
souvent on nous disait vous mettez les
mini-jupes mais il faut vous attendre
que forcément vous soyez agressé dans
les rues soit par des plaisanteries soit
par
des actes
madame Gasquet est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est la libération
sexuelle qui entraîne ce genre de
réaction
vous êtes choqués vous aussi par ce
sketch
je le prends
la libération sexuelle
je crois que les hommes ont toujours été
ici sont toujours ici
on peut pas changer les mentalités
j'espère que oui j'espère que oui mais
comment faut-il s'y prendre d'après vous
avez des enfants comment vous venez pas
d'enfants je crois qu'il faut beaucoup
plus libérer la femme que ce que vous
étions libres de votre thème moi j'étais
quand même assez évoluée et c'est moi
qui joue que les autres et tu as évolué
oui
je trouve qu'il faut un peu en finir
avec cette expression de libération
sexuelle on en a plein la bouche enfin
c'est quoi c'est uniquement et encore
une fois la libération sexuelle des
hommes et pas autre chose que la
libération des hommes et et les femmes
se font complètement coincées là-dedans
parce que on leur dit c'est un nouveau
piège alors quoi vous n'êtes pas libéré
vous faites les plus dis bonds les oies
blanches une fois de plus elles se font
coincées il ne s'agit qu'une libération
que d'hommes et que d'un sexe que
d'hommes alors il y en a marre attends
on va entendre un petit peu les
téléspectatrices madame doyen qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé de ce qui vient
d'être dit
pas les limites choquant mais enfin
c'est vraiment exagéré quand tu es la
libération sexuelle moi je pense qu'elle
a toujours existé moi je pense que c'est
plutôt les masses Bédia qui ont créé ce
terme et qu'un en fait ce qu'il en est
maintenant mais en fait est-ce que vous
croyez que dans la publicité ou dans
certains magazines cela peut être un
symbole de la femme la femme objet etc
mais je pense pas que femme enfin se
ressentent comme un objet quant à moi
pas du tout j'ai jamais dit
vous croyez aussi qu'il faut changer de
mentalités
qui en quelque sorte crée la
civilisation la civilisation qui crée
les mentalités je crois que c'est un
problème parce qu'en fin de compte nous
vivons quand même dans un univers
érotique sous prétexte de créativité il
y a une très grande liberté dans ce
domaine et il suffit de regarder et ne
serait-ce que les journaux dans Madame
parler à l'instant mais il faut regarder
également les affiches de cinéma
la femme était allée elle est vendue au
plus offrant moi il est dans le prix
d'un billet
je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
revoir sur ce plan des mentalités
justement et tout le monde concourt à
cette exploitation commerciale mais ça
ce n'est pas un délit en matière
judiciaire mais vous considérez que ça
peut constituer le moteur d'agression
sexuelle
également l'érotisme qui si vous voulez
pousser à l'extrait mais surtout au
mauvais goût et la pornographie vous
c'est effectivement la question sexuelle
vous avez déjà parlé avec des gens que
vous avez été amenés à interroger à la
suite de plainte est-ce que vous vous
avez une idée un petit peu de leur
motivation enfin je ne parle pas des
exhibitionnistes qui sont peut-être un
cas plus pathologique mais de des hommes
qui pratiquent la plupart on ne sait pas
ce qu'il nous a pris on a vu une
impulsion à une pulsion on est surpris
même la plupart sont même surpris de
l'acte lorsqu'ils sont seuls je ne parle
pas des viols d'adolescents en groupe
c'est différent lorsqu'ils sont seuls
ils nous en avons été de nombreux je
crois que la réponse à peu près
identique et
l'interrogatoire à ce moment-là est plus
du domaine du psychiatre que du policier
le policier se doit lui de constater
naturellement si vous voulez d'établir
le dossier judiciaire qui sera ensuite
soumis au tribunal mais je crois qu'ils
septise psychiatriques à ce moment-là
très important donc pour vous dire pour
vous en tant que policier ces gens-là
sont des malades
je crois qu'il ne faut jamais ni
généraliser ni être affirmatif dans ce
domaine au CD délicat je vais demander
au psychiatre ce qu'il en pense est-ce
que les gens qui pratiquent ce genre de
choses sont des malades ou est-ce que ça
peut être n'importe qui on parle de
pulsion
[Musique]
ça me paraît difficile il faut
distinguer selon les cas entre les
adultes comme l'a dit Monsieur j'attends
aussi des adolescents les enfants
mais
et puis il faut distinguer si on se
s'adresse à un niveau individuel
c'est-à-dire si on prend le point de vue
de l'individu lui-même si on prend le
point de vue de ceux qui ont subi ces
agressions ou si on se passe à un niveau
de société
et l'utilisation qui peut en être faite
ceci dit
moi je pense que ce sont des gens en
effet qui ont des perturbations de leur
maturité psychosexuelle disons mais que
dans le sketch de Guy Bedos ce qui est
un sketch d'homme fait par un homme bon
nous sommes il l'extériorise toute une
fantasme
et je ne suis pas sûr que il s'assoit
qu'un phénomène de civilisation elle
peut prendre dans une civilisation
donnée à un moment donné des formes de
données mais je ne crois pas que ça tous
les hommes de tout temps et toutes les
femmes
ont un rapport à leur sexualité ou ses
fantasmes là peuvent aussi intervenir
quel que soit les lieux les personnes et
les temps je trouve que Guy Bedos il est
Monsieur lambda ah mais vraiment
monsieur tout le monde et si on parle de
perturbations de la maturité
psychosexuelle alors bon moi d'une
certaine manière je dis que que tous les
hommes qui m'agressent dans la rue et
qui m'empêchent de vivre ma vie sont
atteints de perturbation de leur
maturité psychosexuel c'est monsieur
tout le monde il ne fait que dire que
d'exprimer que montrer ce ce que la
plupart des autres nous sommes au bord
des lèvres et dès qu'on refuse de
rentrer dans leur jeu il veut très
immédiatement après de [ __ ] et ils ont
la claque au bout des doigts et
l'insulte au bord de la bouche
à Monsieur Chatelain qui est un homme
est-ce que vous sentez concerné parce
qu'elle dit est-ce que une situation
monsieur Bedos dans son sketch n'est pas
monsieur tout le monde d'ailleurs
j'entendais et lire tout à l'heure je le
lui disais j'entendais ce tour du rire
de femme car en fin de compte
qui ne fait pas tellement rire en
réalité je voudrais poser maintenant une
question aux téléspectatrices puisqu'on
en arrive à parler des solutions qu'en
pensez-vous que faut-il faire quand on
est obligé d'une agression madame
Gasquet il faut se défendre il faudrait
apprendre à faire du judo il faudrait
quoi
écoutez je trouve qu'il y a pas beaucoup
de différence
il y a pas beaucoup d'abris pour les
femmes en plus maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il y a 40 ans
et si on se revisse
on gagne pas longtemps vous voyez moi
j'ai essayé
ben je vous assure que monsieur est
descendu et moi dans le métro que je me
suis rebiffé
mademoiselle mère vous n'avez pas
d'autres solutions vous le dites c'est
assez étonnant que de vous balader avec
un couteau sur vous oui il y a peut-être
une autre solution j'ai dû penser tout
de suite peut-être vous balader avec un
couteau sur vous c'est pas rien quand
même oui je sais mais c'est sécurisant
pour moi si vous voulez j'ai recouvré en
dernier ressource je sais bien que ça ça
sert à rien en fait parce que vis-à-vis
de la légalité c'est interdit non il
faudra oser donner enfin
mes coups de couteau c'est le niveau que
la paire de vie que je trouve pas le
premier poche je pensais c'est
psychologiques tout dépend des
agressions sexuelles naturellement mais
dans certains cas je crois qu'on peut
aussi essayer de de comprendre l'homme
qui est en face de soi dans certains cas
je crois que ça peut peut-être marcher
et vous qui est quand même très révolté
tout à l'heure ça vous paraît possible
ça te comprend entre le côté et la
compréhension il y a quand même une
distance là je dis ça mais j'ai jamais
vraiment eu une agression sexuelle
vraiment poussée je ne sais pas quel
serait ma réaction en fait on obéit à
des un instinct qui ont réfléchit pas
dans ces cas-là je ne crois pas alors
enfin la réponse à ça il faut quand même
le dire elle ne doit pas être une
réponse individuelle elle doit être une
réponse collective de femmes qui se
mobilisent ensemble pour faire cesser un
état pareil enfin moi je connais une
femme qui dit il y a pas de couvre-feu
pour les femmes c'est vraiment le cas
donc je crois qu'il faut il faut une
mobilisation de femmes qui s'assemble
entre elles et qui mettent au point une
forme de lutte qui qui soit qui emprunte
absolument tous les moyens possibles et
il existe actuellement par exemple SOS
femmes battues c'est pas exactement
enfin c'est une agression sexuelle elle
soit femme battue qui sont des femmes
qui mettent à la disposition des femmes
agressées un lieu un lieu de parole un
lieu d'hébergement un lieu où elles sont
pas seuls je m'excuse de vous
interrompre et vous avez là un discours
militant je voudrais tout de suite
demandé au téléspectatrices est-ce que
dans le cadre d'agression vous aimeriez
vous rendre dans un endroit vous
exprimer quelque part et parler de ce
que vous venez de vivre avec d'autres
femmes donc on est temps pas seul madame
Laurens non je le signale à la police si
ça se produit mais ça se limitera là
parce que je pense que c'est une
agression individuelle
[Musique]